>> There are a couple of other points to note about this exercise.
An important question in our [INAUDIBLE] is, what knowledge does one need.
It's not a question of putting in a lot of knowledge into a program.
Instead, the real question is, in order to accomplish a goal what is
the minimal amount of knowledge that the AI agent actually needs?
Let's see how this applies here. The goal was to show that the object is a mug.
Instead of putting in a lot of knowledge, the agent starts asking,
what do we need in order to show that the object can protect against heat?
What do we need to know to show that the object is stable?
And then it goes about searching for that knowledge. The second point to
note here is, depending on the background knowledge available, the agent will
opportunistically build the right kind of causal proofs. So if the agent knows
about the wooden spoon, it will approve this proof. If, on the other hand,
the AI agent knew not about the wooden spoon but about the oven mitt,
then it could use this particular proof. Which proof the AI agent will build,
will depend upon the precise background knowledge available to it